dix ans dans le monde numérique c'est un
âge vénérable et cet anniversaire c'est
aujourd'hui que twitter le célèbre ce
réseau social s'est notamment imposé au
cours des nombreuses révolutions un peu
partout dans le monde
mais twitter at il encore sa place match
du gabon soir jean c'est lui alors
mathieu dix ans quand même c'est long
qu'est ce qu'on fout qu'est ce qu'il
faut retenir de ces dix dernières années
mes premières enquêtes whittle c'est
gros regardez ce qu'on voit à l'écran
c'est un livre en fait ce livre là c'est
une seconde de twitter a enregistré le 9
novembre 2012 à 14 heures 48 et 36
secondes 5000 tweets est un designer
graphique felipe guyane qui ai fait ça
donc c'est gros est-ce que c'est assez
groupe des noms des costauds
l'ex pdg de twitter a dit qu'il voulait
faire du réseau un espèce de perron
d'église globale bien ne pas réussir ses
320 millions d'utilisateurs dans le
monde 10 % de taux de pénétration
seulement au québec c'est vrai par
exemple qu'à tout et on a vu sur twitter
on a vu naître le le mot clic
c'est une innovation d'ailleurs d'un
utilisateur ça nous permet de regarder
la télé en gains et en groupe c'est
aussi un réseau qui a permis à des
débits des doléances politique de montée
de la base avec des mots clics on ne
peut interpeller des policiers bref
c'est une nouvelle manière de pratiquer
le réseau social mais manifestement
c'est pas assez
mais pourquoi alors on se pose des
questions sur son avenir à ce point
c'est à dire que toi tu perds de
l'argent 500 millions de dollars l'an
dernier sur des revenus de 2 points 2 1
milliards on l'a dit les utilisateurs
plafonne ans quand on compare à
snapshots et 100 millions d'utilisateurs
snapshot n'a que 5 ans instagram 400
millions messenger 800 millions watts à
1 milliard bref il ya beaucoup de gens
là dans le monde des applications
alors comment expliquer alors ce
plafonnement c'est celle que nous les
autres plateformes ya beaucoup de
plateformes de beaucoup d'autres
plateformes
l'interface en rebute plusieurs faut
dire aussi que des gros problèmes de
gestion des commentaires haineux qui ont
nuit en fête au confort des utilisateurs
sur twitter notamment des commentaires
sexistes des commentaires racistes les
gens aussi qui arrivent sur tout et tu
contribues peu ans dans les 100 millions
d'utilisateurs qui se sont joints à la
plate forme au cours des dernières
années
il ya beaucoup de gens là dessus qu'ils
ne viennent que regarder donc on e
partie
pas tant que ça en caricaturant direct
sur twitter les gens viennent regarder
des vedettes se parler entre elles et sa
nuit quand même au réseau est évidemment
une difficulté à monétiser donc cette
audience la bref des travaux d'hercule
pour jack dorsey ans l'ex pdg qui est
revenu à la tête de toiture est ce qu'il
va faire la même chose que steve jobs
réussit à réaliser avec à pop
la question se pose pourtant pour
beaucoup de gens n'allaient difficile de
s'en passer aujourd'hui l'absolu mais
j'aime pas un milliard de journalistes
dans le monde c'est bien dit inquiet
pour mon plaisir céline